[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey mater hi hanging there as one of the
same I got fun comfortable the guy
videos checking right around the same
same messages through basically is me
letting us hear is making me feel like
he regrets helping me right now so I
don't regret helping you yeah I would
love to help you
Tamura Amanda hey my second video today
I just wanted to say my thoughts are
translated in my machine so you should
think about that like somebody is
thinking and typing so I'm not trying to
make that stuff to truth like they can
make me feel like all this muscle truth
so it's not a healthy to really listen
to me because it makes people my last
video because just one last video
because it makes you paranoid and
nervous so I just really wanted to say
that out and I love Almighty
I love Michael dove everybody autumn ski
mark hey right here and I'm it how do
you spend your time this I just know I
should be murdered because I'm just not
fitting in I'm just too much of a
liqueur and listener and I'm saying the
world is awesome we don't [ __ ] with that
so no matter how do you spend your days
now well I spend my days talking to
myself
basically shaman do you have any friends
I mean I can have friends but the
systems is fighting you two I feel like
everything has the same things people
will mix the world just too
nervous
[Music]
girge like to be in a year
flying is the system scamming me cuz
like I know I'm at a point where I mean
overall the person I am I became I hope
you know can they continue to give
people these systems because it helped
me feel I know the best me is too much
of a listener and liquor so I'm just not
ready for this run realist man liquor I
just noticed you gotta have money bang
I'm saying [ __ ] to sit on so I mean I'm
a minority to lose some mmm I was just
telling I mean my mom guys so what she
didn't um your dad's very helpful
you know he's cool he's cool you know
it's never good he can't be hey you're
lucky to ever dad you do yeah he's real
soulful and American is this one's the
best for you he's for me yeah but you're
a handful yeah you're difficult yeah
it's two months yeah I need to go
Isaac oh so you guys can chill huh thank
you
so Amanda it seems like the medication
that your dad and I are giving you seems
to be helping you
yeah my my name is low so let's just
keep it low you know Sierra may be nice
and pretty yet I changed it to low so I
just want to explain like I didn't know
I know things sometimes so we started to
garden the people that robot me to
remind me of things so I'm so sorry for
any pain that I caused anybody or
anything
how you guys doing I just wanted to make
another video and watch the office
because I wanted to talk about the
feeling I get when I get high and guys
good morning it's just not good you know
Chan and how I would act if you guys in
fix me up America I think that I've been
I'm asking like that so long is this
like it should it's natural you know tan
maybe they should stop robot at me so I
can see but it's just lying I just don't
like we all got to check out that
feeling that I get when I get high you
know and it's not just about Michael
seeing me that I'm sloppy I mean it is
but it's just like I just don't like
that feeling so you guys gotta check it
out enjoys fun mm-hmm that's it
all right Amanda what's going on I was
just gonna say like I'm sorry fair and
the pain that everybody's been through
if you look at my storyline I'll take
pain very very seriously um when it
comes to the media and me and I being in
the media I don't care what's going on
anymore if I hear music or someone just
like turn that radio on catch it
mm I don't give a [ __ ] what's going on
as long as people not in rooms and
painting or people not in paint
I've realized now I'm like answering
directly feels like maybe I did it but
it's like now that I see like scams and
how people get scammed because I feel
like I was scammed in my storyline you
don't know what people doing you don't
know nothing that's just a video that
I'm doing it or even that's that's
manipulating you know I'm seeing people
know how I am with no life you know I'm
hearing it made me see things that other
people don't see and I feel like people
see me though they got used to it
so they probably retorted like say cells
you know I'm seeing with certain things
cuz they can't sleep with it but that's
not me getting on them right now you
know I was here just overall the [ __ ]
was going on in me I can't even watch TV
that [ __ ] hurts me I turn that [ __ ] off
they just sent a feeling I don't know
what that means
all I know is the storyline in my head
they like making me look stupid and they
don't want to see me in a certain way
and there are certain times where they
like do this now or this will happen do
this now or this weapon so I don't be
doing those things I'm like [ __ ] you I
wanna get some crack like I'll be lazy
UK me but I do this now your whole world
was saying you do this now or am I
gonna do this now and you'll be up to
million dollars I'd only doing that
stuff in my storyline my I'm just like
it's always a situation and then they
had get in my hair right now saying I
don't know what's all this what's going
on with something I don't know who scare
me the surprise of celebrities I think
so I'm gonna see something in the media
and get mad I'll be fine as long as
people aren't in pain I'm gonna [ __ ] K
you wanna put me in pain take me out of
pain right now and we'll talk we'll talk
business about money money you can't I'm
sure you wouldn't mind giving me money
if you didn't ask me and you're over the
whole situation so that's this it's not
her it might be somebody else I don't
know I'm just talking on my storyline no
matter what pain are you in I'm in
mental pain because I give you here the
crimes am i hitting and it's like it's
not enough and it's like I realized I
try to treat crack like it's crystal
weed and that's a mistake so I might get
on Christopher we all I know is I'm
always on my way to my last heat and
then I'm supposed to be in executed or
whatever if I'm dying and they calling
me then I got a problem with that I
don't want to be cloned and that's what
you don't want to be following bedrooms
were you having sex I see some white
girl yesterday they said the same thing
was happening to her she was mean
compared to another girl some sexual and
they're saying think I'm cool cuz I said
that that's what I'm saying
somebody is scared of me being cool and
I get that whoever you are I get that
you know I'm scared that's it what do
you see for your future for my future I
see myself getting educated together so
that all this pain will stop they said I
switching roles and eyes tom day I know
I God before you know I'm seeing I don't
know if I want I'm not being seen on the
Loki so this boy cuz he's putting me
forever pain that's what I'm saying I
just notice right now not a problem with
the girl I just started ringing
I just know I don't know what's going on
so the way people are scared to say I
don't even talk right
nothing's gonna add up to the feeling
and I don't know why that's why I see
things people don't see and that's why
be worth the life setting new stuff like
you know I'm seeing like oh we need a
words and his we need a feeling snitch
so I don't know what I'm saying
Oh something wrong with all this stuff I
just know they send the failures I know
I think I was given a machine with a
story line cuz I have no friends I
definitely can make friends that's what
I'm saying I know I can make friends so
who put this but it's also helping me
you know see and they gave me a way
surgery and all this stuff they're
saying in the surgery they put something
around my heart so that when I'm
electrocuted I'm not gonna die so I was
just being forever pains and singing so
I don't know that's behind me over on
some [ __ ] right I got over a nervous
condition so I don't want a guy but I
seen we try behind our faces will be
going all right so I'm like
I can't beer and I don't like being
uncomfortable soul I'm on my way to my
last [ __ ] give me like a big guy speech
and I sit there and I do run away but
then sometimes I get into conversation I
exactly uh I know why I'm come I get
hives in your head that's the Machine I
gotta tell the machine the machine be on
son I'm just about to cry I'm like knows
how you giving me crying it's like I
need it for water or food you don't and
so the next time I take my last year I'm
gonna get on some turns sheet on the
machine and hopefully it'll kill me they
sang in my way surgery that uh they put
something around my heart so yeah be on
the lookout for a place for somebody
with a gun or something to come shoot me
to get me on a pain I didn't put no
money in pain if you see my storyline
like nah this girl is not gonna put
another anything and that's why I can't
commit suicide because the seriousness
of the painting oh I know people with
money they go through different
situations where it's okay to kill it's
ok MLS it's okay that's still and all
this stuff and then they retorted
actually selves to forget and I'm still
here I don't know if my storyline became
real to the world but somebody said yeah
so know if you're asking like me and you
don't want me to see that you're acting
like me I don't care
like baby's gonna give me gas cuz you're
like a celebrity then let me get that
guys you alright you know my wife I need
some love I need some confidence okay
but overall I'm on my way to my last hit
in my storyline if I don't get killed
I'm thinking right now to my last hit
right now and I turn up and you know I'm
Sierra
then I'll go to the police and I'll go
through them it's wrong I'm gonna he's
this last year turn up
it doesn't kill me there I mean I please
go to my song or go to sleep on the
street and so my daddy's home my another
name God everything will go being in
this room today your family and a few
other people that have known you in the
past are trying to help you
no they're not yes we are okay yes we
are
you're the one who's being resistant
yeah and do you see that maybe you're
getting in your own way in terms of
maybe getting your life together and you
think I'm a different person then you
want to look to somebody else's
orthodoxy marry and they telling me to
show me that I'm nothing and I'm that to
teach me to show me what I am to the
world versus what the storyline is
telling me but I don't have no life and
we are my life you see things exactly
the way they are it's telling me that
certain things that is boosting my
confidence but you're going to see that
that fuel is going somewhere else other
than me thinking I'm all that and it's
telling me that in a textbook science
project mathematics way that that's
what's going on there's different means
running around your electronic around
the city and stuff like that and I want
to know who is doing that you need to
stop because the way I am I'm not gonna
know where nobody am i exactly today I
said when I was smoking away in the car
and then I'm gonna get murdered like you
know they're on behind the scenes I'm
annoying everybody and then I get
murdered I definitely know I'm not
supposed to be here anymore I look very
young somebody take my growth spurt
whatever out of my body that's what I'm
saying whoever this is you that's not
saying for future um for future
reference if somebody is scamming you
don't get on their most um you know she
ain't get on the problem you know yeah
I'm thinking you're all that so what was
I saying
now I forgot but I know the main thing
is that's what's going on so I'm not out
here trying to beat nobody else the
storyline is trying to show me something
that fuel for the confidence thing is
going somewhere else and I can feel it
all day and if you see me out here
Amanda with skin I'm real humble so just
know that I gotta fire you spend your
day just basically looking but gonna
scare me up some me on the computer i
singing this music and somewhere that's
being read Amanda it's a Larry time
scare me I made it you basically spend
your day hunting yeah why looking for
crack right yeah my last Hey
I have a story line in my head I'm on my
last head I'm thinking my voice is being
done by somebody else who sitting at
home with their homies and they're doing
this because of something that happened
with my ex-boyfriend where he was
cheating on me cheating on me at his job
I'm at home calling them are they the
women are going to drive to cheat and
they're saying this [ __ ] basically this
hot hits because basically I don't want
to keep bringing up just because I know
people with money loss [ __ ] or whoever
they like to go they don't like to
remember the same stuff their whole life
so I feel like I'm being a burden you
know Chan to these people and I don't
even hang out with them so in saying
something about something they don't
want me to be the face of it every time
they bring it and then I want to know oh
she put me on to that so I'm trying to
show them first why anything
everybody anybody if I become close to
somebody I'm selling but I don't know
Louise heater nobody so that's it that's
it bye we're here over on cheating on me
in pee and I'm calling them all day and
that makes the sex better you know that
makes the sake Hey
so they said that they gave me the story
line that down here in the surgery
because that happened and I keep
escaping or whatever and sometimes I get
quite a bit of our conversation just
regular exactly I'm always in regular
conversation with myself all this hi
so you think I'm getting high when I'm
doing all day anyway so thank you